عندما كان منزل أركنساس للسترات الصفراء
نقف حاليًا على ما كان
ملعب كرة القدم الرئيسي لمدرسة وين
الثانوية، انظر إلى هذا، إنه أحد
الهياكل الخفيفة التي كان من المفترض
أن تضيء هذا الملعب، يمكنك رؤية
بعض الأضواء المكسورة هنا أدناه  نحن
ولكن ما يذهل
عالم الأرصاد الجوية هو القوة الحقيقية
لهذا الإعصار القوي الذي مزق
طريق الدمار هذا بصعوبة للحصول على
المنظور ولكنني سأريكم صورة جوية
ما تنظرون إليه هو
العشب الاصطناعي المقشر الذي كان  تم امتصاصه
بواسطة التيار الصاعد القوي لهذا الإعصار
هناك ولا يزال في مكانه على
مسافة ثم انظر إلى ما
ورائي هنا مثل قشرة برتقالة
مقشرة للخلف هذا هو ما تبقى تاركًا
الصخرة مكشوفة تحتها وخلفي
يفوز باللون الأصفر  السترات المعروضة بفخر على
برج المياه هذه المنطقة تلقت
أضرارا كارثية كبيرة
أجنبية